Humans are proud of a lot of things from particle accelerators to poetry,
to Pokemon,
all of them may possible because of something humans value extremely highly
intelligence. We think of intelligence as a trait like height or strength.
But when we try to define this things, get fuzzy. In a nutshell,
intelligence is a mechanism to solve problems,
especially the problem of staying alive,
which involves finding food and shelter fighting sexual competitors or flame
from predators. Intelligence is not a single thing.
It includes the ability to gather knowledge, to learn,
be creative form strategies, or engage in critical thinking.
It manifests itself in a huge variety of behaviors from a
hardwired or instinct like reactions to different degrees of learning to some
sort of awareness,
but not all scientists agree where it begins or what even should count as
intelligence to make this even more complicated.
Intelligence is also connected to consciousness sense awareness is helpful for
problem solving, but we're exploring consciousness in other videos.
So today we'll leave it aside. Okay.
Intelligence isn't exactly. Clear-cut.
So maybe we can think of it as more Nike flexible set of skills,
toolbox basic tools with the most basic
tools in the intelligence toolbox are the ability to gather information to save
is, and to use it,
to learn information about the world is gathered through senses such as
vision sound, smell, touch, or taste,
and helps us navigate and react to the external world appropriately.
But living things also need to keep track of the state of their own bodies,
monitoring things like hunger and fatigue
information is the basis of action for all living things.
And without it you're at the mercy of your surroundings,
unable to react appropriately or flexibly information is much more
powerful if we can keep and save it. So the second tool is memory.
Memory is the ability to save and recall information.
So a living being doesn't have to start from scratch every time it perceives
something relevant memories can be about events, places,
and associations, but also behaviors like hunting or foraging methods.
Some of these like flying have to be repeated over and over until they're
mastered.
This is what we call learning the process of putting together a sequence of
thoughts or actions,
basically a string of repeatable behaviors that can be varied and adapted.
These three tools enable seemingly stupid creatures to act in
surprisingly intelligent ways. The, a cellular slow mold,
which is basically just a single huge slimy cell shows behavior similar to an
animal with a simple brain when put in a maze with food at one end,
the slime mold explores surroundings and marks its path with slime trails,
sort of smearing memories on the ground, as it continues,
exploring it avoids the Mt pathways and finds its way to the food.
Instead of blindly getting stuck in dead ends the slime mold adapts its behavior
to save time and effort.
This behavior is hardwired and scientists can't agree if that's intelligent,
although it does give the slime mold a certain advantage.
These are an example of more adaptive,
smart behavior scientists trained bumblebees to move a colored ball into a
goalpost for a sugar award. Not only with the bees,
very skillful at this behavior, which isn't natural to them.
They got more efficient over time. When several balls were available,
B's chose the ball that they closest to the goal.
Even if it was a different color than the ball, they were trained with
challenging problems. We need even more flexibility,
fancier tools building on the basic tools.
More complex animals have a wider range of problems they can solve.
They can memorize all kinds of associations, connections and mechanical tricks.
We'll call this tool. The library of knowledge take raccoons.
Their favorite kind of food is human food.
Their approach to getting hold of such treats depends upon an assortment of
theoretical and practical skills that makes them master burglars,
able to open windows or pet locks in a study.
Raccoons were given boxes secured with different kinds of logs like latches
bolts plugs or push bars they need.
Is it less than 10 attempts to figure out how to open each box?
Even when different locks were put together into increasingly difficult
combinations that had to be solved in the right order and with different amounts
of strength. A year later, the raccoons still remembered how to open the boxes.
And whereas as fast as when they had solve the puzzle beyond the hour
library of associations and skills,
the most impressive tool in our box is creativity.
This sort of mental ducks tape being creative means producing
something new and valuable from apparently unrelated things.
In the context of intelligence, this means making new and unusual connections,
pairing input with memories and skills to come up with a unique solution to a
problem in another Akuna study.
Researchers showed the animals that by dropping pebbles into a water tank,
they could raise the water level enough to reach a marshmallow floating at the
top one, raccoon came up with a much better solution.
It tipped the tub over another facet of creativity is applying a new
resource to a task physical tools like primates that use sticks
to fish for termites in trees or some octopuses,
which assemble collected coconut shells around themselves as a sort of portable
armor to hide from enemies.
Collecting materials for later use is connected to an even more advanced
dimension of problem-solving planning.
Planning means considering the activities required for a desired goal and
putting them together in a plan when unforeseen circumstances and new
possibilities present themselves,
they need to be assessed according to whether they match the plan or not.
An example of this intelligent behavior is hoarding food to eat it later.
This is an instinctive behavior in squirrels,
but even though hiding food comes instinctively to them,
they still need to use advanced thinking skills to make the best decisions
squirrels examine every night and weigh the time and effort it would take to
hide it against the benefits they would get from each one damaged or low fat
nuts are eaten right away while nuts that still need to ripen go on the
stockpile.
Squirrels also pretend to bury nuts when they feel watched these empty
caches distract rivals from their real treasure.
This is pretty advanced strategizing because to make a plan to distract someone
else,
you first have to be aware that there are others like you that want the same
things, the more complex, the problem,
the more tools are needed in combination to solve it.
So the more tools there are,
the more flexibility of being has to solve the challenges life throws at them,
but even for complex problems,
each animal's individual situation is what counts.
Squirrels are omnivores that defend their territories fiercely for them.
It makes sense to remember where there's food and different locations and trick
that animals to improve their chances of survival.
Sheep don't have any such refined tricks up their sleeve that they don't need
to. They are grazers and live in flocks.
The skills relevant to them are social.
They recognize and remember many different sheep and even humans for years,
a completely different skill evolving and retaining a complex set of mental
abilities. They might never use would be a waste of resources for them.
Humans went the opposite way and invested in an unusually diverse intelligence
toolkits. While this was helpful by accident,
we added another set of tools on top culture.
No single person could ever build a space rocket or particle accelerator,
but thanks to our ability to work together and to share knowledge across
generations,
we can overcome challenges beyond any single individual's ability.
This allowed us to shape the planet to our liking.
We also created new problems in the process, Sudoku tax forms,
string theory,
but also rapid climate change and antibiotic resistance to solve
these we'll need to look past short term survival and think about the distant
future. We have the toolbox, we just need to use it.
Speeding. Speaking. You have tools for learning.
We've heard from many teachers that are using our infographic posters in class.
So we asked what would help them most and made an education edition for
teachers, students, and everyone else.
There slightly larger posters about various things that will expand over time
from a periodic table to a world map or the human body.
You can get them in our shop and support us if you want.
And let us know which post topics you want for your room or classroom.
This video was part two of a three-part video series relating to big questions
of life and the universe made possible.
Thanks to a grant from the Templeton world charity foundation,
you'll find our sources and further reading in the video description.
[Inaudible].